bonsoir fabrice di vizio merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
olivier ferrand qui a consacré
aujourd'hui son point presse aux
conséquences psychologiques il est vrai
que les français sont plus dépressifs
qu'avant par aman les dépressions ont
doublé ces deux derniers mois une
stratégie claire aurait pu éviter cela
selon vous on sait que le flou n'est
jamais très apprécié par les populations
je crois d'abord qu'il faut bien se
souvenir que nous avons un gouvernement
anxiogène que franchement pas être
dépressif après les neuf mois vient de
traverser avec jérôme salomon qui venez
vous dire tous les soirs égrainé les
morts avec le président de la république
nous explique on est en guerre qui
maintenant vous expliquer les 9000 morts
attendu que air est tout on a un
gouvernement anxiogène la panique de ce
gouvernement a forcément rejaillit sur
les populations les plus fragiles et les
plus exposés donc nous avons un
gouvernement qui est à l'origine par sa
propre communication déjà effectivement
d'un certain nombre de troubles
psychologiques majeurs
il a angoissé les populations il a mis
les populations en panique relayé en
cela par une partie du corps médical qui
se succédaient sur les plateaux télé et
qui au nom de la prise de conscience
virait à l'habitat tueur de l'émotion
nous sommes devenus fous mais vraiment
littéralement cette communication du
gouvernement j insiste une nouvelle fois
va conduire à des morts et peut-être
encore plus que le co lead
alors c'est vrai que je me fais l'avocat
du diable mais peut-être que les
français n'ont pas toujours respecté les
règles on l'a vu cet été
est ce que le gouvernement n'a pas été
obligée peut-être de jouer la peur pour
tenter de de convaincre et de remporter
l'adhésion
vous savez madame la peur c'est l'armé
du faible
la raison et larmes du fort d'abord
c'est pas vrai que les français n'ont
pas respecté ce qui nous ont encouragés
à partir en vacances c'est les
gouvernants eux mêmes ce qui
effectivement a géré le déconfinement
n'importe comment c'est le premier
ministre lui-même
quant à vos images là que je vois en
même temps que je parle qu'elle est dans
l'intérêt est ce que vous faites ça pour
le cancer est ce que vous voulez qu'on
montre effectivement des patients
atteints du cancer
vous voulez qu'on voit des poumons
noircis par le tabac pourquoi on fait
pas ça alors pour toutes les pathologies
il y à une dictature de l'émotion qui
s'est emparée de ce qu vite parce que
soyons clairs et soyons honnêtes cher
c'est une aubaine incroyable c'est une
aubaine incroyable pour les médias qui
ont des choses à montrer
regardez effectivement ce qu'on voit au
moment où je vous parle c'est une
aubaine incroyable pour le gouvernement
parce qu'en instaurant dictature de la
peur une démotivation de l'émotion il
arrive à des fins qu'on ne l'avait même
pas imaginer dans le pire des scénarios
on va arriver progressivement un vaccin
ou avec un espoir de se faire vacciner
contre une pathologie qui finalement
fait un nombre de morts près manque il
faut se souvenir du chiffre comme très
relatif on ne sait rien de ce vaccin
mais c'est pas grave on va se faire
vacciner quand même et si vous voulez
qu'on soit vacciné et adhérer à des
mesures totalement absurde et de plus en
plus attentatoires aux libertés et
bagnac une solution jouer sur la peur et
ça marche quand je vais je vais vous
taquinez puisque vous nous taquiner
c'est une aubaine aussi pour les avocats
puisque vous êtes vous portez les
plantes de nombreux soignants contre le
gouvernement dans cette gestion de
l'épidémie où vous en êtes
quelles sont vos chances justement de
deux succès dans ses plaintes parce
qu'il ya ça aussi peut-être on le dit
souvent qu'ils poussent aussi le
gouvernement à sortir le parapluie
ces plaintes au pénal que les ministres
subissent ils ne prennent pas les bonnes
décisions
je vais quand même répondre à l'effet
d'aubaine pour les avocats en vous
expliquant que moi je m'en serais bien
passé de ces plaintes
on vous expliquant qu effectivement si
nous avions un gouvernement qui avait à
peu près gérer la crise correctement et
que nous n'avions pas eu imiterait santé
qui était bien nous expliquer qu'elle
savait tout avant tout le monde
eh bien je me serais bien passé de ces
plaintes je me serais bien placé passé
d'avoir des soignants au mois de mars
qui allaient dans les hôpitaux
apparemment avec un virus au combien
mortel sans masque je me serais bien
passé dans a représenté des familles de
soignants décédé
c'est sûr que je m'en serais bien passé
et que les soignants décédé se serait
bien passé également effectivement de
cette situation quant à la question de
savoir qu'on nous en sommes dans les
plinthes et bien les plaintes sont en
cours
la cour de justice de la république vous
le savez effectivement a fait des
perquisitions ces perquisitions sont en
train d'être et exploiter nous avons le
parquet de paris qui a ouvert une
information judiciaire et nous avons
effectivement une plainte contre jean
castex qui a été rejetée l'arrière parce
que celle ci émane est une association
qui estime ton n'a pas d'intérêt à agir
et n'a pas effectivement de légitimité
et bien c'est pas grave je vous annonce
très officiellement que entre demain et
lundi environ 1000 plaintes vont être
déposées contre jean castex par des
citoyens excédés de cette situation
excédé d'être pris pour des imbéciles en
permanence
excédé d'être infantilisés et excédé
qu'on joue sur leur peur puisque la
seule chose effectivement ce
gouvernement comprend c'est la justice
parce que c'est la seule qui nous reste
et bien nous la ferons valoir
mais nous allons je termine là dessus
droit dans le mur et à une vitesse qu'on
ne soupçonne pas alors il ya désormais
la lueur on va dire et l'espoir d'un
vaccin
le gouvernement espère bien ne pas
louper le coche cette fois-ci vous êtes
confiant quant à la stratégie du
gouvernement pour mener à bien une
campagne massive de vaccination
prochainement je veux dire je pense que
pardon mais la personne qui fait encore
confiance à ce gouvernement c'est
qu'elle souffre d'un vrai problème
psychiatrique dire qui est ce une
décompensation psychiatrique c'est pas
possible autrement
je dire que ce gouvernement puisse
effectivement nous mener vers une
campagne de vaccination si ils gèrent
cette campagne de vaccination et si ce
vaccin est aussi fiable qui le dit
effectivement et que sa parole a autant
de poids que celles qu'elle a eu tous
ces derniers mois eh ben je vais vous
dire on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
alors si vous me demandez est-ce que
j'ai confiance dans le gouvernement pour
quoi que ce soit la réponse est non
absolument pour rien et encore moins
pour la vaccination
absolument pas on est en train de jouer
avec quoi avec cet axe inacio c'est à
qui mieux mieux
qui vous dit que les actionnaires de
vaccin efficace à 95% l'autre à 97% dire
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
mise à part engraisser l'industrie
pharmaceutique dans cette affaire je
vois pas ce qu'on est en train de faire
on a une courbe épidémique qu'un train
de redescendre
on a courbé qui débite qui est en train
de se stabiliser on voit bien qu
effectivement les mesures ont servi à
rien je suis désolé vos mauvaises
beaucoup frère de la cdu dont
parfaitement montré hier soir avec des
courbes très significative qui montre
que tout ça a commencé à baisser de
manière flagrante et comme le disait le
professeur ajoute d'ailleurs au passage
bien avant le confinement bien avant les
mesures de couvre-feu et donc on voit
bien qu'on est sur une épidémie ou non
connais pas grand chose et qui
manifestement est en train de se tarir
et on se précipite sur des vaccins comme
la misère sur le pauvre monde mais on
est devenu complètement fou on est
devenus fous et après pardon je termine
on vous fait une histoire de la
chloroquine dont il paraît que c'est pas
prouvée et cetera on fait des histoires
incommensurable avec un traitement vieux
de près de 100 ans dire et là on vient
effectivement donné son adhésion à un
vaccin a qu'une avec une innovation
thérapeutique dont personne ne maîtrise
la nature mais on est devenu
complètement fou on est donc j'ai un
état où on est malhonnête ou on est
juste complètement fou mais c'est l'un
ou l'autre
j'espère effectivement qu'on est juste
fou merci fabrice di vizio avant cadres
soignants et le professeur raoul t et
croyez-nous également que les médias
c'est pas une partie de plaisir on se
serait bien passé aussi d'égréner ses
chiffres de morts et de parler voilà
autant de temps de cette épidémie qui
nous peinent tous merci à vous en tout
cas fabrice sa division